If you haven't finished watching Stranger
Things 2, turn back now!
You can definitely expect spoilers ahead.
The second season of Stranger Things wrapped
about as neatly as you could hope for; Hawkins,
Indiana is once again safe from the threat
of the Upside-Down, and Mike and Eleven finally
got that dance.
Yeah, we're still hurting inside for Bob…
"And...splash."
The rest of the cast made it through the season
with nothing worse than a broken nose and
a
few bruised egos.
But those last few episodes came and went
like a lightning strike, so let's take a moment
to slow it down and look at some of the finer
points of what happened at the end of Stranger
Things 2.
Looming shadow
Let's start by talking about the interdimensional
elephant in the room—the Shadow Monster.
The final frames of the last episode essentially
act as a promise for Season 3, reminding us
that even though the immediate threat from
the shadow monster has been stopped, he's
still out there in the Upside-Down, looming
over Hawkins.
It wasn't quite the cliffhanger we got in
the first season, with a freshly rescued Will
still tormented by visions and coughing slugs
into the sink, but it proves that the Mind
Flayer isn't quite finished with the residents
of Hawkins.
As showrunner Ross Duffer explained it:
"They've shut the door on the Mind Flayer,
but not only is it still there in the Upside
Down, it's very much aware of the kids, and
particularly Eleven.
It had not encountered her and her powers
until that final episode.
Now, it knows that she's out there."
So that… um… strange thing is contained,
but it's far from defeated.
And if he found a way into our world once,
chances are he'll be able to do it again,
gate or no gate.
As we saw several times in Season 1—such
as when the demogorgon broke through the wall
of the school—the membrane between the worlds
isn't particularly strong where these things
are concerned.
Closing the gate
Thanks to Eleven, the gate between Hawkins
and the Upside-Down is definitively closed…
for now.
With the gate closed, all of the Shadow Monster's
influence over our world is apparently cut
off as well.
We see the demodogs go limp and drop down
the tunnel, and the vines in the tunnel shrivel
up.
That doesn't necessarily mean the Shadow Monster
can't find a way back in, but it's a good
start.
Power surge
Over the course of two seasons, we've seen
Eleven's power grow steadily, and it's also
apparent that she's much more comfortable
with the humdrum everyday acts of telekinesis—she
doesn't get a nosebleed anymore with every
little door she slams shut, for example.
But closing the gate clearly pushed Eleven
to her limits—and revealed some of the true
power of her abilities.
Like that whole floating thing.
What's unclear is whether Eleven is channeling
her rage or exorcising it in that moment.
We know that she's focusing on some of the
darkest moments from her past, and earlier
in the season Kali tried to get her to build
her anger as the source of her power.
"I want you to find something from your life.
Something that angers you.
"Now channel it."
Is that what she's doing when she fights back
the Shadow Monster?
Or is she releasing all that rage once and
for all?
Broken hive mind
Whatever the Shadow Monster is, it controls
everything around it through a hive mind,
from the demodogs to the vines spreading out
beneath Hawkins.
It's a pretty scary setup, as we see near
the end of the season.
At a moment's notice, the Shadow Monster can
send an army of killer demodogs anywhere in
Hawkins.
But we're also led to believe that it doesn't
have perfect control over its minions, either.
When Dustin runs into his pet demodog, Dart,
in the tunnels, Dart lets the kids pass, showing
that it can break the Shadow Monster's control
over it if it wants to.
That's an important detail that may very well
come into play in the third season.
Hopefully, the kids will have plenty of candy
bars handy.
Cooking the virus
While Hopper and Eleven head to the Hawkins
Lab to shut the gate, Joyce, Jonathan, and
Nancy go to Hopper's cabin with a comatose
Will and turn up the heat on the thing living
inside him—literally.
By using all those heaters, Joyce, Jonathan,
and Nancy are trying to sweat the virus out
of Will like a fever.
More or less.
"We need to burn it out of him."
It gets pretty brutal, but they're also saving
Will's life.
If that thing was still inside Will when Eleven
shut the gate, there's a good chance Will
would have died along with the rest of the
Shadow Monster's hive mind.
Sure, Hopper was waiting for Jonathan's signal
to prevent exactly that, but would he have
waited forever?
Tunnel distraction
Of course, the rest of the kids aren't idle
during the climax.
Instead of waiting at the Byers house as ordered,
they head out to the pumpkin patch to distract
the Shadow Monster while Eleven and Hopper
work their way toward the gate in Hawkins
Lab.
Their plan: just set a bunch of stuff on fire
and hope the Shadow Monster sends all the
demodogs their way.
Yeah, not exactly the best plan in the world,
but it works—maybe even better than they
expected.
The timing could have been a total coincidence—we'll
grant that—but the moment they set the tunnels
on fire just happens to be the same moment
the Shadow Monster finally leaves Will.
The truth is out...sort of
During the epilogue, one month after the events
of the climax, we see a string of government
trucks leaving a now-locked Hawkins Lab, while
a news anchor voiceover explains that the
government admitted to killing Barbara from
Season 1.
So Jonathan and Nancy's plan worked--they
got the truth about Hawkins Lab out to the
public.
And also like they planned, it wasn't the
whole truth.
Not by a long shot.
Instead of announcing that Barbara was killed
by a monster that came through an interdimensional
rift at the lab, the news claims that she
was accidentally poisoned by an "experimental
chemical asphyxiant."
Because as crazy conspiracy man Murray Bauman
explained in Chapter 5: sometimes you have
to water down the truth to make people believe
it.
"Just like this drink here.
We make it more tolerable."
The upshot is the same, however: by all appearances,
Hawkins Lab is closed for good.
Finally, the citizens of Hawkins get go about
their lives without the government spying
on everything they do​.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!